yes please
go ahead there go to Monte middle third
row honey people NBC Sports Bay Area
Steph what do you take from this game
this is the first time you guys have
lost a game one of the finals game what
are the good and bad things you take
from this this the specific game and
obviously the Bears we were down over
one but it's not the end of the world
you know new experiences for us all the
way through but you know we've proven
our resiliency and ability to win games
that we need to and kind of answer the
bell and learn from you know nice like
like tonight so key call outs or you
know fast break points that they got
whether it's a make or miss for us you
know a couple sloppy turnovers that
really didn't kill us but just add it to
you know their momentum and you know
popsie Pascal had an amazing game pretty
much found a bucket wherever is that and
we got to do all five guys got to do a
better job of just being physical being
alert and we'll be alright
left side in the back on the out go
ahead Nick yeah following up on that
this is the first time since Steve's
been coaches you guys dropped Game one
what do you think changes if at all from
a mindset perspective for y'all dropping
into an early hole like this nothing
really I mean you know there's a great
atmosphere out there they obviously play
well but our confidence remains the same
and block out all the noise about how
you know what these are first and this
and that and and kind of the doubt
around it you know around our team it's
just come out and play hard you know get
game two and and take it from there so
it's I like the vibe I say it a lot but
I like the vibe that we had in the
locker room in terms of everybody
focusing on what they need to do
differently
the overall energy you know bump that we
need to have and and then you know gogo
steel game to right side front row mark
hey Steph mark Medina buried easier if
you guys have often said when things
aren't necessarily going your way that
Kevin Durant's you know an obvious
bailout that could make things easier
besides his obvious score and what other
things were more difficult about him
tonight
katie is an all-time great player on
both ends of the floor so I could sit
and talk for days about what he asked to
our roster you know we've obviously
proven that when he's out we have to
who's gonna have guys step up and you
know that's gonna be the case until he
gets back so for us I think the first
half you know after that ten-day break
it was a little bit sloppier than you
might have we might have thought and a
little bit you know more rust that we
had to shake off but we still have a
chance to win in the fourth quarter and
they did what they're supposed to do on
their home floor and and close out the
game so I don't think it's that
complicated what we need to do
differently it's just play better you
know take away the easy buckets for them
and control them the momentum a little
bit better and we're definitely capable
of doing that you know no matter who's
out there on the floor
Steph side third row army paul in tunis
ESPN Brazil when you see siakam go 14
for 17 and Gasol 6 for 10 and then you
got Van Vleet 5 for 8 do you kind of
live with that and just kind of tip your
hat because you guys seem to do a good
job kind of blitzing Kauai getting the
ball out of his hands I'm definitely not
smiling at them they're saying good good
job guys
it's we can do it things differently a
little bit better be more physical on
them being more aware of where they are
on the floor obviously cause the the
nucleus of what they do and I can say we
did a good job on them of it we have to
keep doing a good job on him but
especially early in the first first half
we didn't rotate well enough
and just make them think a little bit
more they are really comfortable out
there stepping in the open threes a
couple of miscommunications we're almost
like practice shots and obviously they
made them so defensively overall we can
do a lot better job as well as some of
the good things that we did for throw in
the middle Kayla Kayla great TSN I mean
outside of the break you guys don't
really have that much tape to work off
of with this Raptors team I mean I know
you're very familiar with Kawhi Leonard
did you think that that posed a
challenge as well yeah I mean the two
games we had during the regular season
there's guys missing them both nights
and and what-have-you but I'm sure
they're in the same situation not really
expecting or knowing what to expect so
the end of the day they outplayed us
like there's no other way to kind of say
it they did what they're supposed to do
and took care of home court on the first
game and you know no matter what you are
our sites were coming in it's a long
series and two games who was an
opportunity for us to right the wrongs
and and get a big win and go back home
find a question left side second row
mark Steph on the Left mark Schwartz
ESPN draymond said the loss and siakam
was on him he called siakam he said he's
become a guy meaning I respect his his
game what what did siakam show you guys
in this game that perhaps might have
been even over what you thought he was
capable of me as motors pretty much
non-stop so even if you feel like you're
in transition you're running shoulder
shoulder with him he has another no gear
he can get to puts pressure on you in
transition
he showed I know you showed that you
know pretty much all season but tonight
especially when you push the ball on the
floor
he's pretty composed knowing what he's
trying to do with it
obviously greater finishing no matter
you know where it is around the paint
unite down to threes which was you know
big for him to keep the momentum going
but at the end of the day like draymond
said you know it starts with the
one-on-one matchup but it's you can't
give them any dere shots and you can't
give them any straight line drives to
the basket and that's just an effort
thing that we all can be more mindful of
because then today it's not just gonna
be dream on gardening the entire game so
you know you play well and we got to do
something about it
thank you stuff quiets next